- Okay, we're in Vegas.
It's morning in Vegas, which means
we partied too hard last night.
I don't know who's the most hungover.
- I'd say probably me, I'm feeling--
- I went to bed at 10pm.
- 10pm, you went to bed at 10pm in Vegas.
- That's right.
- So before we came to
Vegas I sent out a tweet,
asking where we should get hangover food.
One place sort of stood out,
that people recommended.
It's called KoMex, so we're
on our way now to KoMex.
- [Steven] KoMex.
- We're gonna see just how
good Korean and Mexican food
are curing our hangover.
(soft music)
- I'm gonna give you a nice loud clap.
- I feel like one thing that's
nice when you're hungover
is to just lean against a nice brick wall.
- Is that real brick?
- I can't tell.
- [Keith] It's just a perspective trick.
- [Shane] It's not real, it's not real.
- It's not real.
- Sorry you're having
such a rough morning.
- What's the history of KoMex?
- Well we actually owned a Mexican market
for over 20 years.
We would bring home
bulgogi meats, all of that
and my husband would just actually take
the pico de gallo he had, a tortilla,
just kind of wrap it up and
eat it with Mexican rice,
whatever we had at the market.
- That's awesome.
We want to eat everything.
It's got fries and it's got chippies.
Whoa, baby go.
It tastes like Korean barbecue
and it tastes like french fries.
- It's fun to be messy
when you're hungover,
have like there's messy meal.
- Jalapenos are nice and spicy.
Wake yourself up baby.
- Yeah, man.
- They know how to fix this thing.
- Put your energy down.
- Why?
- Please.
- I'm happy.
- [Brian] Because we're
hangover and you're yelling.
- I can't do with this volume right now.
- The spice opens up my
hungover closed sinuses.
- I want to say it's like if Taco Bell
were very, very, very good.
'Cause you know how
Taco Bell's always like,
well what if it's a pizza.
- Holy moly.
What's better than nachos and fries?
Tater tot, that's what's better.
And I can't believe that
they understand that
and that they serve this as a meal.
The tater tops are
golden, they're perfect.
- You're a little baby.
- You're bullying me,
I'm not a little baby.
- [Steven] Little baby.
- [Keith] Steven, you're not going to
be able to eat that bite.
- [Shane] Hold it in your mouth.
- That's not how anyone
wants anyone else to eat.
It felt like my cheeks just
started sagging to the floor.
'Cause they're filled
with such delicious meat.
- There's nothing I like more
than stuffing my face with tater tots.
- I can't look at your face
while you speak to me anymore.
- Bulgogi chimichanga.
So, it looks like a Mexican chimichange
but instead it actually
has bulgogi meat in there.
- [Keith] This sauce smells so good.
- I feel like this isn't gonna
be too bad on my stomach.
It is somehow light.
- I don't feel light at all right now.
- I feel light, I feel light as a feather.
- This is what hangover food is about.
It looks beautiful when it arrives
and immediately a disaster on your plate
but like a disaster that you
want to lick up every drop of.
- Hangover food should
become a beautiful disaster
like your night prior.
- Oh yeah.
- This is kind of like
one, just big jumbo.
It's one flavor.
- This is more uniform whereas
the other one was like,
hey, have a little bit of this.
Uh, where's this crunch coming from?
- I am waking up, certainly.
I feel like a lot better.
I'm starting to feel better.
I'm stretching.
- [Lynda] So this is the last item.
Koreans, after a drunken night out,
want something spicy and so
this is a kimchi chicken fried rice.
- Can I pop the the yolk?
- You can pop the yolk, bro
- You did that so--
Why did you do it like that?
- I'm sorry.
- I actually normally don't eat kimchi
because I know that kimchi's spicy
and normally when I'm about to eat it
one of my friend says, "No,
Keith, don't eat this."
It's like acidic spicy.
- Sometimes spice is a great
way to wake yourself up.
- [Keith] That's true.
- And this kimchi is just
clearing up my sinuses,
opening up my eyes and
getting me ready for the day.
- At Korean barbecue places a lot of times
they'll finish grilling everything
and then when they're done
they'll take all that grease.
- Oh, man.
- And make kimchi fried rice.
Oh, it's so good.
- This is just belly cement basically.
Really tasty belly cement.
- I just love rice, you know.
Fried rice, white rice,
steamed rice, sticky rice.
- Uh, I'm beginning to get a little sweat.
I'm gonna start to glisten,
I'm gonna start to glisten.
So how's my hangover now
as compared to earlier?
I do feel better than earlier.
More energetic and ready to poop.
- My hangover now has definitely improved.
- You kinda looked like
hell a couple hours ago.
- I felt like hell but
now I feel like a person.
Thank you KoMex.
- Coming out of a hangover is
one of the great joys in life.
- As a totally sober person
I really enjoyed that meal
but I feel like I went in
reverse of what you guys are.
'Cause I started off
this morning very awake
and now I'm at that like
food baby coma moment.
Cheers.
- [Shane] Feeling good.
- [Keith] Feeling good.
(happy jingly music)